okay we have a voicemail number two one
nine two david p this is a really funny
voicemail this is meant to be a parody
of some of the really dim right-wing
callers that we get and i don't know if
the implication is that we are somehow
specifically selecting incompetent right
wingers to pick up on when we take live
calls of course i don't do that i just
see a phone number and i pick up on
phone numbers that I've not seen before
but this is so funny because it's
something about this it's like yeah that
actually is you're not even really
exaggerating this is what a lot of our
right when caller sounds like take a
listen my question is you know about you
know i you know form a because i am a
typical david pakman show caller i'm a
troglodyte I'm a virgin and you know I
wouldn't even know how to go about you
know even forming a question I don't
form a question before I call it okay
right I never form a question I have a
very bad connection
I don't know Louis metonymy I don't know
I don't know the fake beef between you
between David Pakman and Sam see I'm a
total virgin you know
okay so my question is for someone
looking to get better at the David
Pakman show
right you know I mean I don't even know
I don't even know your producers first
and last names by heart I know there's a
backs I know there's a pat I know
there's a there's a you have an ad
agency and you took angel investors dude
I don't even know I mean I don't even
know where your shoot I think I think
you're out of your mom's basement is
that right that's exactly right yeah but
you know for someone who's pretending
not to know a lot of the stuff
the show you seem to know a whole hell
of a lot about it my friend but yeah
okay so troglodyte virgin calls into the
show and actually sounds like a lot of
the right-wing callers that we get I
don't know what we've accomplished with
that little experiment we've got a great
bonus show for you today
Twitter has blocked or locked rather
Mitch McConnell's campaign account
because they posted video of protesters
shouting threats and profanity hilarious
Barcelona has confirmed that women can
swim topless and city pools because of a
gender equality rule law I guess we
could call it and we will talk about the
contagion of mass events contagion of
mass events and being careful about how
I word that for specific reasons which
will become clear on the bonus show two
ways to access it become a member at
wwe.com or a patron at patreon.com slash
David Pakman show